all right next question for you eric uh
how can we improve sleep to help
training
sleep's getting big i feel like more
than ever you
the last couple years you hear a lot
more people talking about sleep as it
pertains to athletes and training and
stuff like that which is a good thing
because i think uh
i think we ignored it for a long time
like we used to always
it was always like a thing of pride like
we got our guys in the gym at
four in the morning it's like yeah but
they all went to bed at 11.
yeah you know it's like that's that's
not a great for the whole like i'll
sleep when i'm dead
well congrats bro like you're going to
die 20 years earlier now
yeah yeah you'll have a great
opportunity for that
um so there was a recent review paper by
vitaly
at all in 2019 open access so anybody
can read it
what they did was within the paper they
gave a couple lists of recommendations
and instead of
you know running my mouth for 30 minutes
and and trailing off i'm just going to
give you the good stuff get right to the
lists with the highlights here
so one was called the healthy sleep
hygiene top 10 recommendations and their
source was
was the ucsd center for pulmonary and
sleep medicine patient information
handout so they went ahead and
republished it right there
in the paper number one don't get don't
go to bed
until you're tired if you're in bed and
you're not tired get out of bed go do
something
i think that's one that i rarely hear
but that's a really good piece of advice
like there's nothing worse
than just laying there and staring at
the ceiling not at all helpful for your
sleep habits
number two get a regular bedtime routine
what's this face you're making that uh
that first piece of advice
um actually just like
ruined my sleep for about five years why
because you would just
bail on the concept of sleeping and go
work i mean
dude so so people say
you know humans are supposed to you know
have a natural
24-hour sleep-wake cycle um
i'm about to tell like a greg is a
special snowflake story
don't don't hear this and think that
it's going to apply to you
so you know if i
don't go to bed until i'm sleepy i will
generally just like pull an all-nighter
maybe like once out of
every three nights and it's not just you
know
like when i don't have stimulants in my
system when i'm not on screens
um i still just don't get tired until
i don't know maybe like six or seven in
the morning and then at that point it's
there's no point in going to sleep
because i'm either gonna get like two
hours or
sleep through the entire next day but
this is one of the reasons why like one
of the pieces
of advice i was given when i started
having sleep issues is
oh read a book to wind down that doesn't
[ __ ] work for me
because i get engrossed in what i'm
reading and then
next thing i know it's 9 00 am my wife's
waking up for the day
and i'm like 80 of the way done with the
book and i'm still not tired yet
um so like in general that's probably
good advice
uh i previously took that advice it
didn't work well for me
now i just like force myself to get my
ass in bed sometimes i stare at the
ceiling for four hours but
i do on average sleep much more than i
used to
yeah i mean no one should be taking
their sleep queues for me
your situation is just different like
you're you're the person in the sleep
study that has to have their data
discarded
no yeah for sure yeah for sure what
you've got going on is strange
but number one don't go to bed until
you're tired if you're not tired get out
of bed
till you get tired number two have a
regular bedtime routine
um you know reading a warm bath don't
unless you're greg you know because you
start reading and all of a sudden you're
done with the book number three try to
get up the same time every morning so
routine is big for a lot of people your
bedtime routine what you do before bed
the time you go to bed the time you wake
up
try to get a full night's sleep this
list says to avoid naps
i think people are moving away from that
in the sleep research i think naps are
getting
a lot better pressed than they used to
but ideally i think the scenario would
be that you sleep so well at night that
you don't feel inclined to take a nap
later in the day
use your bed for sleep and intimacy only
don't do a bunch of other random stuff
in your bed don't be sitting in your bed
doing homework and stuff like that
avoid caffeine avoid alcohol don't smoke
or use nicotine
especially within the hours preceding
bed avoid
super high intensity exercise right
before bed usually i think just a couple
hours
is enough to wind down from that but you
know obviously you don't want to
finish a sprint workout and hop right
into bed uh
bedroom should be dark quiet kind of
cool you don't want it to be warm
and then they had some other tips and
tricks now the blue blockers are getting
pretty popular i know eric helms
reviewed a study on them in mass a
couple issues ago
so avoiding blue light specifically a
couple hours
before bed can be a nice thing one of
the things i find interesting is now
they're putting a lot of those led
stadium lights in
and like led street lights those things
are
awful in terms of the amount of blue
light they emit so like if you're in
like an
outdoor you know flag football league
and you're playing until like 11 at
night under some lights
that actually might be tough it might be
pretty tough
um a good idea is to get some bright
natural light in the morning so this
blue light it works both ways right so
it kind of stimulates wakefulness so
it's nice to be exposed to light in the
morning but to try to kind of withdraw
from that within the hours before bed
uh one one on the list that people hate
don't hit the snooze button
that's a battle that a lot of people
have given up on
and i'm one of them i need to get better
at that if you use your computer at
night there are some things you can do
to reduce the amount of blue light
that's coming out of it either via
software or i think there are actually
physical covers as well that you can get
higher carbohydrate meals especially
high glycemic index foods at night
might be helpful super high fat meals
right before bed can be a little bit
detrimental and some people really
struggle if they have really spicy
high fat meals before bed kind of keeps
them up from just their
gi being a little upset melatonin can
work
uh don't want to get into all the
specifics on how to dose and time that
because it's kind of a whole can of
worms there
but that's really the only supplement
i've ever felt really solid about as it
pertains to sleep
uh there's a bunch out there but
melatonin is kind of the
the king of the sleep supplements i
think uh don't fall asleep with the tv
on and i would say
you probably don't want to do that with
the radio on either um you want to
eliminate any kind of stimulation that's
going to disturb your your sleep quality
here's one that's really really big that
people forget
you gotta taper your fluid throughout
the day you you shouldn't be waking up
twice to urinate in the middle of the
night a lot of people that like
are like no i gotta drink two gallons of
water a day or something especially in
the physique athlete world
you gotta taper that stuff down there's
nothing cool about having to wake up and
didn't you say you used to purposely
make yourself do that
uh yeah so i used to it was when we were
talking about
drinking a protein shake in the middle
of the night yeah i'd purposefully drink
a bunch before i went to bed so i
i could wake up in the middle of the
night for my protein shake
dude you violate like every single
aspect of this list
no so dude like these days i'm doing
virtually everything on this list
um and i accept except for the first one
of
waiting until i'm sleepy to go to bed
everything else
i'm mostly doing i'm being a good boy
okay
i'm sleeping at least six nights a week
it's been
awesome what's your average hours per
night you think
i don't know um so
i pulled an all-nighter this week to
finish an article but i would say in
general i'm probably averaging
eight uh and and sometimes that's like
getting in bed staring at the ceiling
and getting five
and getting like 11 or 12 on the
weekends but
yeah i mean i'm i'm sleeping more like a
real person these days
that's good all right last two uh
as i already mentioned sleeping in a
cool room tends to help out quite a bit
and check your mattress might be too old
that's a helpful tip but uh yes there's
a lot of different things you can do
that affect your
not just the amount of sleep you get but
also your sleep quality
i think that's something that people
should consider a lot of times people
it's like well i went to bed at this
specific time
and i woke up at that specific time but
sometimes
they fail to account for the fact that
they're rolling around all night
and they're still tired all day despite
the amount of sleep they're getting
sleep quality is also really important
so there are some people who
even though technically they sleep seven
hours a night or something it's like
we still probably ought to look at this
checklist and reevaluate if you're
potentially
hurting your sleep quality which is
still causing you to be really tired
throughout the day
just one more thing i would note as well
since there are
i mean i would assume virtually everyone
that listens to this podcast is a lifter
if you're doing everything you think you
should be doing and you're in bed for
enough hours
and you do still feel super tired all
the time it's not
a bad idea to go get checked for sleep
apnea
that does disproportionately affect
lifters because
one of the main risk factors for it is
having a thick neck
and so i mean i don't think a ton of
people do neck
training but i think most people's necks
just naturally get a little bit thicker
from lifting
um so yeah if you do constantly feel
super tired all the time
if a partner has complained about you
snoring constantly
uh not a bad idea to get checked for
sleep apnea
yeah i i recently was struggling to
sleep for i mean for like a million
different reasons but one of them was i
was waking up because i was breathing
poorly
and i have a deviated septum from
wrestling because i used to just slam my
face into people
my go-to wrestling move and
it explains a lot about my current
appearance but
um so i thought it was like oh well you
know deviated septum hard to breathe
then i started using like an allergy
nasal spray
and it's like nope you just had
allergies just didn't address it for
like six months but yeah so
anyway moral though the story is make
sure you're breathing well when you
sleep as well
um but yeah it's a lot of that stuff's
pretty obvious but i think
i think a lot of people and i've i've
fallen into this trap as well it's like
when you're sleeping poorly it's like
something
that has happened to you that you have
no ability to influence you're like well
the sleep gods have frowned upon me
lately and it's like well there's
actually some behaviors that you can
that you can proactively address to try
to increase the likelihood
that you'll get good sleep sometimes
people will go through all these and
there's something else going on that
they have to go
and get some assistance with you know go
see a sleep specialist
your physician might refer you to do
like an overnight observation period
so it's it's not to say like if you're
if you're sleeping poorly it's your
fault
because you're not doing things but it
is nice to know that there are things
you can proactively
manipulate to try to enhance your
likelihood of sleeping well